Owen Shroyer is being targeted by the
doj they want 120 days in prison why
speech
Owen Shroyer a pundit personality and
journalist for Infowars
said some things
and for the things he said the doj says
he should go to prison for it and this
is what I said was going to happen I
said now they're going after they go for
Trump they go after his lawyers the next
people in line are going to be the
pundits who are advocating for or
encouraging people on January 6. first
person in line Owen Shroyer now a few a
few important details he did not go into
the capital the Infowars team had a
permit to have a rally outside the
capital in a different area Owen Shroyer
was on Capitol grounds this is the
initial pretext they get to charge him
he pleads guilty they then say in the
charging in the sentencing document the
prosecutor says because of his speech
before during and after the event
he should get this amount of time in
prison